[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar bienvenida feliz lunes feliz
inicio de semana hablemos de la reunión
que tiene lugar en la organización
mundial de la salud que está reunida en
esta asamblea general para así lograr un
acuerdo contra las futuras pandemias
buenos de raúl feliz lunes pues sí
empezamos con esta es la segunda vez en
toda la historia de la organización
mundial de la salud que hay una asamblea
extraordinaria eso nos da una pista de
lo importante que es esto que se está
hablando hoy se terminará la reunión el
1 de diciembre el miércoles ya hay un
borrador inicial y gran parte del debate
está en que si este tratado contra
futuras pandemias será vinculante o no
para hablar de todo esto de esas
amenazas que pueden estar nos esperando
en el futuro estamos con carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia doctor
muy buenos días como cada lunes gracias
por acompañarnos cuéntenos qué tan
probable es que volvemos a enfrentar
alguna otra pandemia en el futuro
claro es muy probable porque nosotros
tenemos esa amenaza patente de los virus
que no han desaparecido pero además de
eso tenemos esta disrupción en el medio
ambiente que cada vez es más frecuente y
digamos la migración la universalización
de nuestro mundo hace que estas
enfermedades ya no tengan una frontera y
que puedan afectarnos sin duda esto es
una emergencia esto fue un gran llamado
realmente el colon es una infección de
baja letalidad a pesar de todo el número
de muertos que hemos tenido y pueden
venir amenazas mayores y no estamos
saliendo del cobach 19 como para que ya
estemos hablando de una nueva pandemia
autor los saludos feliz lunes le
pregunta entonces que debemos hacer
nosotros para evitar una nueva pandemia
digamos que todas estas son lecciones
aprendidas nosotros tenemos que tener un
respeto hacia el medio ambiente
fortalecer la ciencia y universalizar el
conocimiento hemos visto como un gran
responsable la pandemia fue la info de
miao que ha sido responsable de la
abundante información sin procesamiento
y todos desde nuestro punto de vista los
científicos los políticos los medios de
comunicación la sociedad tiene que
entender que tenemos que aprender para
seguir avanzando y poder protegernos
entre todos esto no son actos
individuales en altos colectivos para
poder superar una crisis como la que
enfrentamos doctora estaba hablando de
la info demián o como uno de los errores
también que hemos cometido durante la
pandemia de kobeny 19 pero más desde una
perspectiva de salud pública cuáles son
esos fallos que han habido de respuesta
global frente al cobat 19 de los que
podemos aprender
un problema global no se avanza con
respuestas individuales y las respuestas
organizadas y la organización mundial de
la salud pues debió liderar en procesos
hizo un papel importante pero no
fundamental
este es como el kubán el estratega
kóvacs para que llegaran las vacunas a
todos los países pues ha sido lenta y ha
sido parsimoniosa ha logrado hacer cosas
pero muy poco con muy baja velocidad yo
creo que eso ha hecho que no se confíen
en los entidades multilaterales y estos
problemas globales lo que ven es
fortalecer estos elementos
multilaterales tuvimos al principio la
pandemia que eeuu se retiró por una
parte política de la ms y esos tipos de
errores pues los tecno más pagando todos
porque terminamos universalizando una
enfermedad y teniendo una respuesta muy
tardía doctor deberíamos entonces
impedir que países con más dinero
acaparen recursos médicos como por
ejemplo las vacunas
yo creo que el llamado la solidaridad
tiene que ser en la abundancia y en la
abundancia porque la solidaridad es un
proceso y estas enfermedades son
globales entendemos como las grandes
economías de eeuu china en américa
latina brasil pues fueron arrasadas en
su población por el virus aquí no
depende la capacidad económica cual
depende de que todos trabajemos juntos
la industria farmacéutica la ciencia las
políticas la sociedad civil todos
tenemos que trabajar en conjunto y yo
creo que aquí las capacidades económicas
ante la fragilidad de como humanos ante
un virus no sirve para nada es trabajar
juntos para podernos proteger juntos
precisamente de eso también quería
preguntarle no hay muchos países que han
tomado decisiones muy individuales o
centradas en proteger su población
nacional mientras que estamos viendo que
la respuesta a las pandemias debería ser
global teniendo en cuenta que esto es
precisamente lo que se está debatiendo
hoy en la organización mundial de la
salud podemos ser pesimistas o
optimistas frente a que esto cambie
pues nosotros tenemos que ser optimistas
y realmente optimistas porque es el
único camino ya entendimos que la
infección no tienen fronteras no tienen
digamos que la migración de los humanos
ha hecho que esto sea universal y
nosotros no podemos seguir pensando que
si un país tiene 50 veces más vacunas
que otro país a este mejor oeste no le
ven mejor nos dimos cuenta que
independientemente en las tasas de
vacunación de las tasas de educación de
la población la enfermedad está
afectando a europa alemania y todo en
general aquí vamos a actuar en conjunto
sobre todo conciencia con sensatez y
sobre todo con el aspecto más
fundamental que es ayudarnos todos
doctor pues muchas gracias también por
ese llamado a responder globalmente a
una enfermedad ya una situación que nos
está afectando también a todos y va a
decir a todos por igual pero en verdad
no nos está afectando muy desigualmente
entonces precisamente por eso ese
llamado a la unidad nos vemos el próximo
lunes doctor muchísimas gracias así es
doctor marc gracias y vamos a seguir
hablando de pandemias y también de la
nueva variante del coi 19 con nuestra
segunda mitad al día